welcome back everybody this next very
talented singer was born in Oklahoma
went on to become a K-pop Superstar then
came back to the US to dominate American
Song Contest in 2022 her latest single
is called sick check it out wherever you
get your music everybody say hello to
[Applause]
[Music]
Alexa
this is my favorite thank you very much
my makeup artist wears a black one like
that all the time and I'm like you're so
Chic and what is that like you you're sh
you're cool you're cool congratulations
once again on American and all the
success that was been that's so cool
what what was it like going back home
like after that big win and then you've
been on the road aive I I have been on
the road in the air on the ocean in
between um it was crazy though I mean
for one I still can't believe that it
even happened I mean getting to meet you
know someone have idolized my whole life
County Clerk that was like that was like
me and Snoop that was like me with Snoop
yeah I was like oh my God I know he was
so fun oh and amazingly productive
stoned yeah yeah yeah I was like wow
okay so what so you're from Oklahoma and
I kept I remember hearing that the first
time on the show and I was like K-pop
where did the influence of that come
from like how long have you been into
K-pop I mean you know the k Oklahoma
K-pop totally so much it's a big thing
there
now it is though that's a surprising
thing it's a big thing everywhere my
nephew and niece are obsessed and my
children really as they should be but uh
so my mom is actually from Korea she was
adopted when she was five uh so I really
never had any like you know yeah that's
me as a tiny squishy
babyy but I had no connection to my
culture or like the Korean you know
language or anything growing up like not
even joking the only connection I had
was a jar of Kimi we always had in our
fridge my mom and I always had do anyone
like Kimi yeah okay I don't know if I've
ever tried it but you're like the third
person to bring kchi up on the show and
I'm like how have I never tried this I
love food you should try it yeah yeah I
would probably love it is it kind of
like a it's not a sauerkraut thing is it
like it sits for a while similarish it
is fermented like spicy cabbage
basically love I would love it you
should try it yeah I should bring a jar
next time I'm into all that well you
don't have to bring gifts you can just
bring you yeah it's okay you're enough
so when you spent a lot of time in Korea
right yes I've been living there for the
past six years now so you love it then
if you're that much oh my gosh love it
yes yeah what's your favorite thing or
what is the thing that most surprised
you about it oo um well for one like you
know how like restaurants and like bars
close at like 2 a.m. 1: a.m. in America
Korea there's so much 24/7 like bars
cafes restaurants my god do they get
anything done okay we get so much done
that's the surprising thing like we work
work work work work like Korea is very
workaholic it's it's a productive place
to live but another thing that surprised
me being from Oklahoma mosquitoes are a
thing yeah yeah but the mosquitoes in
Korea are like massive really yeah like
you know normal mosquitoes here are like
that big stand mosquito but the ones in
ker are like that big and like if I'm
laying down in bed and I look at my
ceiling I see one I'm like oh no and I
stand up and I just the and I get
attacked it is so funny my daughter and
I will get we will have a thousand red
bumps on us and my son will not have one
what does that mean what blood type is
he I don't even I should know because
from from what you should know I should
know I'm sure it's on a card in my
wallet somewhere but cuz apparently
mosquitoes like certain blood type well
they must love a positive cuz that's
what I am a negative so oh my God it's
bad it is yeah they lied to me too when
I moved to LA they were like oh it's so
beautiful the weather and a mosquitoes
it is mosquito City it is bad they lied
to you they lied bad yeah this is what I
did not know about K-pop I found out via
my family actually um but they there's
storytelling in it so there's a whole
like characters like four people in
K-pop like you have a backstory that's
what they do that right I do yes I love
this well great I love imagery so yeah I
mean most artist mean you're person
yourself but yeah K-pop itself is a very
Visual and concept driven uh genre dare
I say for back of a letter word letter
word oh my God better word yeah back of
a back jet jet lag it's jet lag lack of
a better word did you have some of B's
whiskey back there I did not indulge but
now I think I shall so but lack of a
better word K-pop is a very um visual
conceptual genre so typically artists or
groups will debut with a concept like
they're like oh they're a bad boy or
they're like the refreshing like school
girl Concept in my case um the team and
I were discussing what my debut concept
should be we wanted to be original
Innovative and we were like oh like the
Cyber Punk AI concept hasn't really been
delved into yet so we went through that
and that had a whole trilogy from debut
up until
my third album release Revolution and
then we've kind of kept the whole like
cybernetic cyber Punk stuff woven
throughout the rest of my story little
bit of AI in there yeah yeah yeah that's
a cool concept thank you do you all ever
make like like many like short films
with stuff that yall do because that's a
really good idea I have good ideas she
she has are you listen Len I'm saying a
really good idea CU then you B the whole
thing I love the concept it's like
Beyonce did that with liit she did like
a whole concept album too with that yeah
it worked it worked very well very well
but uh I feel like that's one of the fun
things about K-pop I mean nowadays of
course artists all across the globe do
very cinematic music videos and
storytelling but I feel like K-pop kind
of not originated but I guess K-pop
really made the Cinematic if that's a
word of music videos we're making it a
word yeah we are it's very prevalent so
like most music videos will have a story
beginning middle end and like after the
song is over there's going to be maybe
even like a minute to two minute long
clip at the end to give more of a
cinematic feel like it's just very fun I
I love the storytelling of it so what
what about sick that's the the song
you're doing today right okay what's
that about we decided that this year
2024 we're going to expand to the
American audience a bit more than Korea
itself and I'm going to be doing music
in English specifically yeah uh so
that's going to be fun that's cool just
to do both languages that's cool yeah
and sick itself it kind of tells the
story of like whenever you're in love
with someone or maybe in a relationship
with someone but you feel like they're
too good for you they're like out of
your league oh you're so perfect you
make me sick like that kind of feeling I
like do we know what we're talking
anybody felt that I like this okay but
this is relatable personally I interpret
it a different way where it's like same
scenario but instead of you think
they're perfect they're kind of full of
themselves they think they're all that
in a bagg of chip they're like I'm so
perfect I'm so Godly blah blah blah and
then you see that and you're like o
That's unattractive that makes me sick
yeah next yeah you love that too yeah I
love that about music and things and G
you get you take what you want from it I
love that so much well we need a quick
commercial break but Alexa's new single
is called sick y'all got to check it out
and she's performing it later on the
show so stick around we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home